Good morning, everyone.
I'm on the barnyard,
as you can tell.
Hi, girls.
My heifer gave birth yesterday.
Milky and a heifer can be a little bit tricky
because they're not used to someone tugging on them.
I've done this a couple times now.
Hello, Danny.
Right here is a head gate.
So she'll put her head through here.
Of these little pan there,
so she can't get out while you're milking.
Let's go, daddy.
She's contained.
She's eating her grain.
Now we're gonna get to work on milking her.
Staunchen, we only use for training.
Maybe for a week,
two weeks. To paint on the cow.
What I love to put on is some superior cow cream.
This is for swollen,
utter sore teeth.
Peppermint cream.
It has that, like, warm,
cold sensation.
Wanna be facing this way so your.
Your hand can be like this.
We're obviously not saving today because train. Yeah,
we're training.
As she kicks, you don't wanna let go,
you let go. And that's training her that.
That if she kicks,
she gets relief.
Keep your hand on the teeth.
I'm gonna try to do two.
And she's doing great.
So this right now is just colostrum.
Her milk hasn't come in.
Dairy cows, they produce more than enough colostrum for their calf.
So just like dairy cows produce a lot more milk,
and it takes just to raise one calf,
the same with their colostrum.
My hand right here is.
Is cramping. We're Okay, good.
You're okay.
We got done with one side.
Hahaha.
It's Stella,
Mama